[Music]
why does your mouth feel like it's on
fire when you eat a spicy pepper and how
do you soothe the burn
why does wasabi make your eyes water and
how spicy is the spiciest spice let's
back up a bit first
what is spiciness even though we often
say that something tastes spicy it's not
actually a taste like sweet or salty or
sour instead what's really happening is
that certain compounds in spicy foods
activate the type of sensory neurons
called poly modal nociceptors you have
these all over your body including your
mouth and nose and then the same
receptors that are activated by extreme
heat so when you eat a chili pepper your
mouth feels like it's burning because
your brain actually thinks it's burning
the opposite happens when you eat
something with menthol in it the cool
minty compound is activating your cold
receptors when these heat sensitive
receptors are activated your body thinks
it's in contact with a dangerous heat
source and reacts accordingly this is
why you start to sweat and your heart
starts beating faster the peppers have
elicited the same fight-or-flight
response with which your body reacts to
most threats but you may have noticed
that not all spicy foods are spicy in
the same way and the difference lies in
the types of compounds involved the
capsaicin and piperine found in black
pepper and chili peppers are made up of
larger heavier molecules called alcohol
amides and those mostly stay in your
mouth mustard horseradish and wasabi are
made up of smaller molecules called
isothiocyanates that easily float up
into your sinuses this is why Chili
Peppers burn your mouth and wasabi burns
your nose the standard measure of a food
spiciness is its rating on the Scoville
scale which measures how much it's
capsaicin content can be diluted before
the heat is no longer detectable to
humans a sweet bell pepper gets zero
Scoville heat units while Tabasco sauce
clocks in between 1200 and 2400 units
the race to create the hottest pepper is
a constant battle but two peppers
generally come out on top the Trinidad
Moruga scorpion and the Carolina Reaper
these peppers measure between 1.5 and 2
million Scoville heat units which is
about half the units found in pepper
spray so why would anyone want to eat
something that causes such high levels
of pain
nobody really knows when or why humans
started eating hot peppers
archaeologists have found spices like
mustard along with human artifacts
dating as far back as twenty-three
thousand years ago but they don't know
whether the spices were used for food or
medication or just decoration more
recently a 6,000 year old crock pot
lined with charred fish and meat also
contained mustard one theory says that
humans started adding spices to food to
kill off bacteria and some studies show
that spice developed mostly in warmer
climates where microbes also happen to
be more prevalent but why we continue to
subject ourselves to spicy food today is
still a bit of a mystery for some people
eating spicy food is like riding roller
coasters they enjoy the ensuing thrill
even if the immediate sensation is
unpleasant some studies have even shown
that those who like to eat hot stuff are
more likely to enjoy other adrenalin
rich activities like gambling the taste
for spicy food may even be genetic and
if you're thinking about training a bit
to up your tolerance for spice know this
according to some studies the pain
doesn't get any better
you just get tougher in fact researchers
have found that people who like to eat
spicy foods don't rate the burn any less
painful than those who don't they just
seem to like the pain more so torment
your heat receptors all you want but
remember when it comes to spicy food
you're going to get burned
you